for me of pills awesome to be on that
stage and obviously with Reba and Dolly
and I feel like the tone of this whole
award show is just one of love and
respect and encouragement and mutual
admiration and the open is just going to
be amazing you're gonna see obviously us
up there
but maybe some people you haven't seen
it at the CMAs in a while and just
remembering what is amazing about
country music and about women's roles in
country music what was amazing what
could be amazing
everything in between these are the
women that I've grown up with that I've
admired that I've toured with and on
stage with hung out in dressing rooms
together so it's gonna be a really fun
night of that's what the problem is
gonna be at rehearsals they're gonna
sell pickles girls we got a we're gonna
get to this we're gonna be visiting and
chatting and having a wonderful time
reminisce there are a ton of
performances by females but also moments
where there's other CMA winners that
come up and present or introduce other
people we really just wanted to jam pack
it and just just I don't know just do it
in the in the most wonderful respectful
way and just have as many ladies of
country music in their show as possible
I hope they walk out saying this is a
great night of entertainment I had a
wonderful time got to leave all my
worries at the door I walked in got to
see a lot of talent got to visit have a
wonderful time and then when they leave
the after the show they're charged up
ready to go face the world one thing
that I've always said is really positive
about all of the conversations that have
happened about women in country music is
that we really have all banded together
and made it a point to lift each other
up and take each other on tour with us
and encourage one another and be fans of
one another and I mean I I feel like
this nights gonna represent
that you know to a tee as a big night
for all of us and we just trying to
worry about getting the right clothes
and coordinating their makeup in their
hair and all the girly things
see that's the trouble with doing a show
with all girls you wouldn't believe the
chaos backstage and they're trying to
put more rhinestones on my plane can't
get too many rhinestones wax bark I
never met around stone I didn't like
[Laughter]